thanks to Idol heroes for sponsoring a
portion of this video we're going to
have to make this video twice as fast as
we usually do one week start to finish
we don't get this video down I'm gonna
dropkick everyone Nico
oh I can't do that okay you know how you
wanted to shoot this world's largest
slingshot video yes the client asked us
what ideas do you guys have that are
inspired by the same thing as our game
and we gave them world's largest
slingshot you're going to Hawaii this
week you see this week right here yes so
we can shoo I get back no we can't shoot
it when you get back because we're gonna
go to Portland we're gonna film bike
theft deterrent we have to release
tactical this release date on the 20th
that's the only date that fits we have
to film it next Friday and then we have
to finish it the week after that but
didn't film it the day after we film
tactical reload I don't think we can do
it in a week man take we can do it Jake
we can do it come on
but here are my conditions okay you'd
have to get Wren Clint and Sam all to
agree I know how you guys get when you
all work on something at the same time I
wouldn't be able to post manage the
video you would happen to do that yeah I
can do that you would actually have to
do that though right Jake I will do it
alright next week we're make an entire
video in one week all right
I can do it do you believe me Jake of
course I do man course it of course I do
do bran
what are you doing next week I don't
really know yet perfect
are you helping with the project of
course hey Clint can you set an entire
week helping you with the video yeah of
course
okay tell me if I get to call the shots
what if we both team effort in it okay
good really all right now this is like
already one of the most heavy CG videos
we've ever done and we have a week yeah
first day of tech - cool reloads as we
planned tomorrow's shoot by shooting it
on a cell phone you're automatically
making the motion tracking incredibly
difficult laser gun videos I spent over
a week only motion tracking we had to
write a video in like two hours so today
we to film an entire video in one day
it's the same wacky humor friends
building something extremely dangerous
in this case a giant slingshot and
they're shooting it at a giant garbage
you pile the thing is we're making it
all up effectively on the spot so we're
going to take the time get creative hope
it's not too many cooks in the kitchen
get the acting food out get the can work
for you get the VFX figured out and make
it all work that's what we do here at
corridor digital subscribe subscribe
subscribe there's actually something
really nice about just doing a project
and get it done in a little span of time
he's dead no worry about anything except
us working on the video every day on
silver lining Nikko
so what we have to do is in nearly every
single shot we have a 3d slingshot we
need to add in and we have a 3d garbage
file that we need to add in and there's
a lot of physics simulation and camera
tracking that all has to be done oh and
neither Sam nor I have used cinema 4d
very much so we're gonna figure that out
on the spot on-the-job learning under a
time crunch it's just how we roll my big
task here is just making sure that
everybody's working on something
simultaneously Clint can be at modeling
this thing shot while Sam is doing the
tower while redon can be doing the
ragdoll while I could be doing something
feeling a little salty begin that
process go Satan if Frank gets the rag
doll working and couldn't gets his
slingshot modeled then we'll be in good
shape
who knows there's a shot in this video
where I get flung by a slingshot and so
to do that we need a photo scan myself
we're gonna try to process that into 3d
models typically speaking with the photo
scans you really want to get like a lot
of pictures gives a lot of depth
information really helps to fill out
what you're capturing get no transitions
on these movies
I literally just watched you make no
transition as sick as I got a million
shots in that area what's going on bro
you guys yeah this isn't the time to
like learn if I specifically brought
Spencer over so we could do it right
there and it's looking like we might
have to do it a second time we're
supposed to be working on different
things so we can get this thing done in
a week we're both working on this at the
same time and I think that's to be done
photos' against the for Nico I have done
a lot actually everybody sees the only
impression that I haven't done this
before
people think into the old dog are you
ready why are you guys doing it again um
you know sometimes you just need like
pictures that you think you can see
inside my body here so you know this is
great and all I'm gonna see if there's a
way to basically trim everything down to
just mean from there export a 3d model
decorating is cinema4d
why am i so rough
he's evidence that you need to lotion
all we're trying to do is turn me into a
rag doll and from what I found online
it's not a super obvious process I love
this work man I love making something
look good in cinema for
this is the world's biggest slingshot
I've been working for like three hours
the other half of my day is gonna be
spent building out the sling with like a
rubber stretchy stuff and the rope tied
around everything my wrist hurts my back
hurts it all hurts I hadn't eaten
anything all day there's no time for
actually amen
oh hey so anyway one of the things I do
around here is I serve as producer for
any of the projects that we have going
on every now and then I find myself in a
weird position like I am in today where
I have no one to collaborate with
because Clint Sam Nico and Ren are all
working on the same video meaning I have
nothing to produce someone comes up with
an idea and then they pass it off to me
and me and Christian go out and we
produce the video without anyone to come
up with ideas kind of have nothing to do
every Tuesday we have a writer's
meetings this morning no one was there
but I think I found the perfect thing to
help me pass the time that's why today's
episode sponsor is Idol heroes it's a
little mobile game I picked up to help
me pass the time and quite frankly you
can play it anywhere anytime in fact
it's one of the easiest things to do
around here now that no one wants to
work with me
[Music]
now the game can be played at your
leisure and they have daily tasks that
you can complete in just five minutes
so I keep sneaking a game here sneaking
a game over there and just basically
just watch the time go
the game has six factions with over 300
unique heroes and it's all about
strategy you see everyone on your team
needs to bring something unique to the
table and I think honestly it's gonna
make me a much better producer in the
future you guys are interested in
downloading and playing Idol heroes for
free click the link in the description
right here in this video and find out
what you can bring to the table 5 hours
then this morning I didn't know anything
and now look at us oh that was so fast I
didn't even know what cinema4d
was this morning and you're literally
learning faster than Nick's camera can
right
no no joke literally every step of the
way to get here I had to watch tutorials
or ask Clint
now that I know cinema 4d inside and out
the rest of the week should be make a
rag doll it's this strange doing a rag
doll 3dsmax was super easy I'm at a
point now where it's like it'll be way
quicker to just like literally just
animate me like flying through the air
just from like a feasibility standpoint
these are all effects that are kind of
inherently experimental that thing I got
that for you like two hours ago not
eaten all day
I like dude I built I built a slingshot
so fast but honestly what having trouble
getting this uh rubber in the cloth I
don't have to go home and train harder
if we don't release on Saturday it's up
it's over we throw it away we all lose
our jobs
we're all going we're all packing it up
we don't get this video down I'm gonna
dropkick everyone what's what's up dude
I've been so deep it hurts dude don't
take that one out of context our little
behind schedule today or do the physics
things for every single tower shot we
need to do the physics whims for every
single slingshot shot my snicker-snack
who's worth going on the issues that
we're running into right now you see
those ropes they're not reacting 100%
true to physics this is the first pass
of a slingshot and the stretch bands
that are firing this tire basically the
issue is that these ropes they go loose
on frame one of the launch which isn't
realistic
those ropes need to stay straight all
the way up until the tire reaches right
between the Y ran actually had a really
good idea basically I'd have to hand
animate those ropes for the first like
two or three frames it's not that bad
and then start the simulation from like
that point that way to go as opposed the
right now is like worst absolute worst
case scenario this is passable and then
24 hours from right now we should be
uploading the video because I was going
on about how we schedule things
correctly so we're not doing time
crunches so Clint so stressed out he's
only communicating and cinema4d terms
now I'm gonna try to make him feel
better but you might not understand what
we're saying but bear with us Niko has
to do this clean house your motivation
level is your motivation level in float
at one might change the exposure to
point one to neutralize that will that
work I'm gonna set your gamma 2.05 much
simpler much quicker solved I feel a lot
better now Niko talk to us in serene
where eat my almond I'm gonna eat a bug
big friends lost it I feel better I'm
gonna go tackle this shot
[Music]
do you hear that
that's a beautiful sound it
clickety-click nothing like the sound of
hot keys edits and renders listening
shut good I have all my slingshots
rendered out we just have to comp stuff
now so Ren's dropping in all of the
stuff that has been rendered into the
Edit we're gonna take a look and we're
gonna give notes we're gonna update this
VFX sheet so the four of us can
communicate through this sheet and this
will be our final determiner of like
what's done what needs to be worked on
so this one yeah you need to be rodent
shot to see it basically just needs to
be composited from scratch sling shot
rendered tower render needs rotoscoping
extra too much sharpening right that was
my note it's too sharp 2 hours and 4
minutes we need to have this video done
so I can upload it and send it over to
the client so they can see it and also
prepped for release tomorrow we just
went over all the shots that we have
notes for every single shot so it's all
hands on deck trying to get it done down
to the wire
you got it we're gonna stay late this
Friday hopefully not
[Music]
as far as here for the blue bars dude
action be if FX man godfathers action
pfx looks so good look at during the
smoke is that a volumetric sim did you
do fuel effects no son that's just
action V effects the z-depth pass every
step this takes I get closer to Hawaii
yes action V effects I dropped in a
single explosion element of theirs and
it was just like I sat there for 20
minutes
trying to figure out something else I
could do to make it better
well howdy truck dude it's running it's
functioning it's fully functioning all
right I just wanted to go and get a
couple of beers for for all the boys
they've been working hard all week
please tell me it wasn't non-alcoholic
Coors that you got them
everybody non-alcoholic course it's
gonna be great I got non-alcoholic
course it was to be done we don't get
this video down to stand directly below
the balcony all right human right here
so I mean I guess go to corridor to see
the full video if it's there I'm fine if
it's not
so the Sun is set on Friday and you need
it over to the corridor channel to see
the video make sure it's actually gone
out and these guys worked so hard they
deserve a subscription so if you haven't
subscribed hit that button if you have a
rung that Bell it's a good option I
think you'd like it